tonight sad to say this will be my last
twins broadcast it's been an honor to
work with you dick over the years the
last 25 years god bless you all and be
safe and now let's play some baseball
that is jose barrios looking for his
third win we already showed you his
success against the chicago white sox
they are outstanding numbers but
too many walks 18 walks in 30 innings
pitch so he's got to throw that ball
over the plate make him hit the ball
they can hit the ball but make good
pitches so they could make outs so
here's y'all monkatta first time we've
seen him in a few games showing but
moncada lays it down third base line
brillo's picks bare-handed throws in
time to get him and he is going to be a
guy that's going to win a gold glove at
some point he is so good at fielding his
position
moncada his first game since the weekend
he missed the last three days with a leg
injury the shift was on trying to get a
bunt down a good bunt danny but a better
play we say a welcome back to number 24
here is josh donaldson this is
donaldson's first game since july 31st
suffered a right calf strain while
fielding a ground ball that's way to
line drive up the middle base hit center
field kepler had a weight he's going to
round second hold as robert has a great
arm throws it back in near short so
donaldson
first at bat back lines is single to
center and the twins are in business
here two on nobody out zario in an rbi
drought no rbis over his last eight
games three on one out no score now that
pitch is on the ground to second
madrigal flipped to second for one the
return throws gonna be in time they get
out of it and the inning has come to an
end no runs a couple of hits so 208 jk
who also came out as a pinch hitter
yesterday tripled high fly center field
robert back
now back to the wall leaping it's gone a
home run
cave has done it again against lopez and
it's one to nothing he homered off lopez
earlier this season that was a grand
slam this is a solo shot in the second
and the twins take a one-nothing lead so
two on two out twins one white sox
nothing and now donaldson driven to the
gap in right center field
jeffers around third he'll score kepler
around third he'll score and donaldson
into second with a two-run double
welcome back josh donaldson
donaldson after missing all of august
has two advanced two hits
and now two rbis and the twins cash in
and have a three-nothing lead here in
the second marwin gonzalez is taking
over in right field max kepler
apparently injured a leg when he came
around to score on donaldson's double
here's kepler coming around third and
scoring kind of pulled up right there
this is a huge at-bat for the white sox
with one out a bray you need to at least
get one run in here you swatch this ball
to first it's kicked around by snow who
recovers and throws to burrills but the
sox get the first run
in the visitors column today and it's
three to one now 3-1 game and the batter
is miguel suno the base is emptying one
out swinging a drive left field and deep
beckett goes deep it goes and gone
miguel sano got a second chance and did
not miss it
palmer's out to left that's number eight
and the twins regain the three-run lead
it's a four-one twins advantage
so arise who just can't stand still
and abreu has
ceno cut off between second and third
and now arise is going to advance to
second base and the white sox throw the
ball away there's nobody at home playing
and ceno will score
this is little league baseball at its
best
right now i think that they're going to
give the error to tim anderson who
slipped when he got that feed from
oncotta slipped a little bit then got up
and then there was traffic it was ceno
running to third brayu there also the
pitcher one in one on ground ball right
side base hit the rise going to be waved
around
mazzara no throw as it's going to be cut
off by abrayu so the twins tack one on
and cave with another base hit and an
rbi he has two ribbies tonight one of
them all right
so two down here is robert the bat he's
over two tonight fly ball right center
field
[Music]
here's eddie rosario to bat and that
ball's hit into center field fairly well
long run roberts back on the warning
track jumps up and it's gone
eddie rosario with a two run homer to
straight away center field
and it twinch tack on two more they lean
eight to one we get a new pitcher in the
game devin smeltzer on for the sixth
time at zra over six and a half
hi fastball got him one down it has a
change up right there
here's mazara last hope for the white
sox
high fly center field
cave drifting back now still going back
leaping and making the catch right at
the wall and the twins take two out of
three from the white sox thank you very
much minnesota twins good luck
the rest of the way